[Music]
thank you for attending spice
meeting I shall begin by to treat now
the emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evaporate the
billet in which please leave the
building by the nearest available exit
there are two fire exits in this room if
you need to evacuate the room by the
door to the fire escape staircase please
hold both handrails in case the stairs
are wet or slippery if anyone is unable
to use the stairs but they please allow
others to exit the room before they go
to the fire escape door where they can
be given assistance please do not use
the lift an assembly point will be in
the public carpark at the side of the
Civic suite you do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings do
not return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note this meeting will be also
recorded we cannot please also mind you
to switch your phones off the order to
sign please
apologies for absence we have apologies
wrongly counselor
Macpherson counselor mrs. Mason
counselor mr. Mason and counselor
Stanley substitutes evening counselor
Western Haysom counselor Mountain for
mrs. Newsome counselor Wilson for mr.
Mason and counselor canal for counselors
family and non-members attending this
evening we have counselor mrs. Hoyt
counselor in Walled and Counsell
Williams don't believe any other
counselors at item number five to
receive a declarations of interest
including any you were being
declarations you have done minutes
chairman I'd also have just 60 minutes
ultimate agenda item number for our
members with the minutes and agree these
final thank you apologies moving on to
item number five received declarations
of interest including between deaf
correctional counselor mr. Boyd both
myself in counseling she's however
monthly interest we're actually having
goes to substantive in control
a few questions that were raised the
last the last immunity which scheduled
few tries to come back a bit and give us
an update on those members with a patent
reform which would be so close if not
all members of every chance to have a
read of that if I could just ask you to
just briefly summarize there the four
members I mean just highlighting issues
that you feel very important for us
before answering any questions that
members may have sure this report just
yeah this is in fact we came back once
in March 2017 as well that was the the
first time we came back with the agenda
that we've kind of set as I say then the
item came back again in November 2017
and both times it has been sort of a
progress report on where the services
compared to where it was when we first
came to the meeting in March 2017 the
report sort of as it has with others
we've stripped it back a bit so it
basically sort of concentrates on on
those five points about where we want
the service to be so it sort of briefly
introduces the main focus and purpose of
the service as a local authority
Building Control Service focusing on the
needs of residue
it outlines the statutory frameworks
that the current control officers
operate within sets out the the fee
charges and again the regulations for
that on implementation of the new
structure it's been summarized there's
five points that we've been
concentrating on those the first one
being recruitment to the vacant posts
which is ongoing we have permission to
advertise for the senior building
control officer role and I believe
interviews are taking place tomorrow
afternoon for that post hopefully we
will be after then advertised for the
building control officer post so there's
there's four roles within that team and
that's team leader to senior Ben control
versus and a building control officer
post and at the moment we're operating
with two permanent staff one agency
staff member
until we can recruit those the next item
was reviewing procedures and processes
and richard has engaged in a pilot
quality management scheme to understand
how how those processing that's with
local authority Building Control and
that review is ongoing another aspect
that was discussed at the previous
meetings was restoring the reputation of
the service making service accessible
and you know we looked at how we could
do that through various different media
other than just sort of you know taking
telephone calls to to deal with cases so
we set up a specified dedicated email
that comes into the team so that it can
process
another new aspect as being a smartphone
app which has been rolled out
particularly with with builders and
those who use the service regularly so
that they have better channels to to
book services quickly and get those
inspections online and providing details
of what they require of the building
control officers there's also online
payment of fees which is sped up that
process and obviously once engaged then
the officers can go out on site visits
once the fee has been has been agreed
in addition officers have looked to kind
of provide with the speeding up of those
processes it provided more time for the
building control officers to focus on
that customer services aspect to build
the market share to to get that
confidence back in in those who use the
service regularly so that so that we are
competing well with approved inspectors
and the privately owned building control
officers in addition point four is
review of the charges that we have to do
in line with the sit for guidance they
have been reviewed and benchmarked and
they are there to ensure full recovery
at this point in time it was there was
satisfaction of the last update was
still in line with what we should be
charging for that service point II is to
develop a training matrix the issues
with with planning and building control
both services have a skills deficit it's
being sort of quite prominent in the
media over the recent years cuts courses
discouragement of officers or graduates
from taking up the post because of risk
of actually having a job at the end of
their courses you know with cuts to
services so it has been difficult to
recruit into roles because people don't
have those specific skills that officers
have developed over the last 30 or 40
years and that's why in a lot of cases a
lot of skilled building contractors are
available building control officers are
further down further down they're there
their time as an officer sort of coming
up to retirement age a lot of them so
Richard is being sort of working on ways
to improve that and looking to get those
specific academic qualifications and
looking at sort of in-house training as
well as a sort of appraisal process that
can help to understand what skills those
surveyors need to ensure that they can
deliver as a building control officer
because there's sort of specific aspects
that they need to understand to allow
them to do that as I say you know it
outlines that we're running at 50%
permanent staff at the moment because we
are finding it difficult to find those
offices and officers who are qualified
tend to stay at the authorities there or
work for agencies and maybe three or
four times the salary that they would
have earned as a permanent member of
Building Control so it is difficult we
are trying to sort of improve our
reputation improve ways that people can
use the service but we we are still
fulfilling that need to recruit a full
team as part of that so at the moment we
aren't running at full capacity to
achieve that indicates a efficiencies
yet
council probably stuck with you
to last a few from the read the report
in November 2017 on the way the minutes
don't reflect it was mentioned that
there was a business plan I'm still
disappointed we haven't as a treaty seen
the business plan I was hoping it was
going to come to this committee but it
still hasn't done so that's what I
started doing from some of the things
mentioned today by mr. Thomas such as
star phone app for not know they were
mentioned in the report on the 7th of
November for it and so he's just trying
to see where we've moved on from since
that meeting because we was told at that
meeting that perhaps if he saw it now
food we would see how it's progressing
and what's happening so I would say that
you know we were mentioning a desire to
use a smartphone app we are now up and
running with a smartphone app also just
on that payment of fees is that
something that wasn't being done just
about clarification for new members and
that's something that wasn't being done
previously or just wasn't anything that
didn't exist used in a meeting in
accessories and yeah I'm going to move
on to that one I'm having heavy cruiser
plague as well I think there's some
education has done to be taking place
within the council because when trying
to pay our fee to pop into the office
which probably forgotten you couldn't do
that anymore
and then we were told to phone up and
then luckily Richard dictators there's
an online app online a business language
but very well to be honest so I think
there's some education around the
council services around how people
campaign as well which might be helpful
and on getting that
there's all obviously not obviously but
I'm assuming that some of the problems
with staffing overnight are causing a
problem answering the phone because
obviously we found there's no answer
well people do get back to us but then
sometimes this was one of the problems
originally with bill because that would
fire them no one would answer well
that's still a long day which is why the
we're trying to use the melted
multi-channel approach which is which is
although we the point we did have the
spot at a loss maintained but we hadn't
implemented it and we had it available
good set it up and tested it but we
hadn't we haven't got the take-up that
we were looking for to avoid people
having the problem phoning in so when
you have a problem phone again you get
demonstrated the app or site and we put
it on to the builders phone with the
Builder all right so as soon as we have
the contact problem which we can't
resolve because we haven't got enough
stuff in the contact center so we've got
wait times to twenty to forty minutes
sometimes so we're not we can't resolve
that because that's not something that
I'd control as a manager so instead of
trying just leaving it and not doing
anything we we've we speak to the
Builder we regularly in contact with
them and when we go to site we say how
did you get on getting hold of us and as
soon as they say let up onto the phone
we put a phone app onto their phone so
we we also give them help to how they
might use it so for example if you just
have a phone app you won't know what to
put in inside so we go through the phone
app we we talk to them about putting
other information into the other
information part of the phone app to
give us more information to how we can
feel their call better on the day so we
are taking 15 up to 15 or 20 calls a day
between up to 10 o'clock all right and
then we're doing that the same day
so the quantity information they give us
in the request perhaps to get to them
and the times that systems that are not
held up so that's why the apps much more
valuable because if you're phoning in
and waiting 40 minutes
and then you'll get to somebody in the
customer services then trying to
understand where you are with the work
when you want the time of the visit what
and try to understand some of the
technical terms it's probably better if
you put that into the app and so with
that in place and with the building
control inbox which we had but we're
using it in a different way because
members said last time at the meeting
where's your workflow so there isn't any
work for there is no workflow system in
the council where you put working it
backs up times when work is going to be
done it doesn't communicate where work
is to anybody outside the council if
there's no communication going on so you
send something in right you wait for an
answer
and you chase it up because there's no
work for so you can't interact with
where the work is in Building Control
but what we can do is we can put it into
the dedicated building control inbox and
then when we've seen it an action date
we mark it and we create a marker in
there so so many folks our customer
services that are phone two days ago and
I sent some information in what's
happening in red at the top of it it
says what's happened right so they can
then put further information and because
the song hazards away in a week or I
need to speak to them about that so we
we are doing we are trying to create
that work for in place that the payment
system is needs needs adjusting because
we we've managed to do so far is add on
in the misko lanius box right the
building control and we haven't got all
the categories in there either and
that's because it's out sourced so go
through capita so you have to give an
instruction to finance they have to
understand the instruction there to talk
to capital s reactions and all these
little bits so we've just gone for we'll
just get it on there and let's see how
it goes
so that's why when I spoke to you about
doing I had to keep you where it was
you've never find it would you miss
colonias so why we've got car
in a big box and other things and not
the weather defeat where the fees are
most productive for the council in the
in the main section completely it's
worth absolutely so this is your letter
just touching on that point you just
raised there what are you doing now
actively to try and get that payment
procedure a bit more well what we will
still will explore why those icons are
where they are how council wives are
having them there who puts them there
who try to can change them but they're
for the time being we as long as we know
where the payment is we can tell the
customer go into this convenience you
compare it but we think this should be a
planning and building the trophy icon
which you click on and go straight to it
something with that something that we
don't actively look at yes yeah but
there's the sort of limitations within
the system and their historic their
legacy issues people have set these up
and for some reason it was set up
without a building control online
payment system mmm so that's attack
another question how'd you find this one
which is very who it was
without being taught where to go you
have no idea where to go when the
payment site who just resolved used in
the link and told how to do it was how I
managed to the bleep face-to-face just
moving on to the financial side for my
chairman and I think the even November
2017 when you reported I think the
income at that point was about two
hundred and forty six thousand seven
hundred pounds
my big give or take a few budget for the
year now was 265 and I think that was to
665,000 based on a 70 percent market
share the district yes is that on course
still or not
well we were given the fact that you're
down star-forming the expected speed but
we've had to tell work away because we
can't do it yeah and also the weather
was bad within the mmm
and that hit the production in the
construction edition people catching up
on stuff they were behind with so they
haven't been able to take on new
projects so that we are where we were
expecting link to drop the video yeah
but it's not drastically down enough yet
that it can't be chased back again so
bearing in if I if I can get some some
extra time from who I'm looking at
tomorrow then I could start chasing some
of the projects again yeah I just wonder
if my trailer seems to be a problem with
in other areas of the house as well
staff recruitment and retention because
it you know alone all day also has the
same problem I'm just worried that he
might not be fixable in the near future
we're interviewing tomorrow afternoon
but as you say you know we have this
issue in Building Control we have the
same issue in planning where we've had
senior planning offices one post has
been vacant for a year and a half so you
know it's it's difficult with in those
fields there's other fields within the
council wider than building control
planning of it that have these issues as
well and whether you know it's it's the
whole recruitment package whether it's
the salary levels that rot should pay I
mean we've done some work within our
service areas but it's probably that
there is a more sort of general issue
about how we want recruit people
interruption and then retain their
services in the long run particularly
woman we put a lot of effort
particularly with graduates and but then
are training them often and losing them
to to neighboring authorities which
happened to us on a number of occasions
okay Thank You councillor mrs. Shaw I'll
just going back on some that's the high
said we go on I didn't know anything
about what you just got into the LBC
website it says pay for it then it lists
out exactly and it says miscellaneous
and then it shows everything about
building so being a complete novice I
found that very is a very easier to use
so you know I know you might want to do
some work but I've never had to go into
this when my husband died its tribute to
it by paper in shape you know that many
moonscopes okay it's there you know if
people just read it properly we clean up
properly on the computer it does work so
you might have other things you might
not want to look at for us people that
yeah we can continue the communication
yeah with people going it but I've just
gone straight including our problems
over the way the way we work is if tell
us they have a problem not get here to
work we provide them with the
information he has a system there's a
sort of model the business model for us
is really John Lewis you know if the
poor customer has a problem the
customers right
and the customer needs to help and
support to get it right of course but
that's not their fault because they
can't you know things don't look like
but having said that you know however
slick you are people's don't understand
it I look at it just so I think you know
that I wasn't being rude playing on the
machine
first I'll have Thank You Jen thank you
and just a couple of questions I've got
online you mentioned the report about
the pile of quality management scheme is
that you were just a very briefly order
yeah if you like the question as much as
people may know that are following the
benefit our fire govern conditional
various reports into you know the status
of control on buildings and the LAV safe
felt that there was a risk that may be
variable quality with the impending
control you know in some sense function
so rather than wait to be constructed to
produce evidence that we were running
improperly they decided to become the
Quality Manager themselves and so they
it's their each individual Authority
running their own quality scheme that
they they BC was the core team manager
and we're using a process map stored in
our processes against that the standard
is set within that core team adversity
and how far they're my personal we've
done we've we've done the all debt we've
done the ordinance against the processes
and the continue engaging with with ABC
this is a pilot so we've the hardest to
get credit Asia as a quality manager
there they BC and have a set of
processes which we can get all of the
authorities in England than ways to
follow okay thank you very much question
I've got is we've got to the training
you said about the in addition in cash
training based on native the services
being provided I wasn't quite as a
gospel your inspectors who is given that
training I'm doing that it was just so
obviously in-house yeah we're so will we
will look at you know it for example I
get any development of housing and I'll
get somebody to look at it and then
we'll go through it we look at what the
expectation is in terms of getting on
the plans what we need to checks on the
site we look at the process of checking
it on-site
and make sure that the file is tidy so
sufficient to do it that type of thing
so weird where where people are giving
their job to do then I will train them
on the job and give that and if there's
areas where they're weak and are
knowledgeable then I'll go to the
appraisal and they'll have to follow up
leads and get a soldier boy yeah give
themselves more assistance in terms of
looking things up and following things
through and they've got target jobs at
people when they've got weakness isn't
help them to build up their strengths
where they were so strong okay thank you
councillor Lucas kill thanks Jeremy um
do you pick up messages left on the
phone we tell people not to leave
messages or folks we asked them to I've
never been told that before and there
was a Priya in which I was interested in
and I couldn't get hold of the officer
involved and said leave a message which
I did that was two months ago I'm still
breaking yeah but I've talked a little
bit more that sounds like planning issue
yes Ted and follow that I'm few
Outsiders here but yeah I think take
that up if it's planning
Thank You cancer every year your two
points continuing with Richard this
training and that you've just been
talking about with the chairman is there
the opportunity or do we undertake
taking on apprentices commercial
apprentices to train up ourselves with
some sort of sign up for committee to
work for 70 years after he is there a
statutory training scheme that we could
oh we're working on that without a BSA
to join up the various things that are
offered around the country into one
package which has been coordinated by
the University of Wolverhampton so we
already have people who provide weekends
away and training consume their
concentrated training for building
control will people there in it covering
various topics but it doesn't count
towards anything so we're trying to
connect all the different parts into
some kind of modular system yeah I was
thinking more of a younger generation
coming as well yeah until there's
apprentices until we've got that in
place and it's nationally agreed any can
lead to a qualification we would be just
doing our own training for the
apprentice I think you've got to have
that qualification to go with it you
know so we sort of set words like that
sort of September's long time yeah and
the other question is for councillor hoi
you said that you're disappointed that
there's no business plan you've asked
for this previously for us who weren't
on the review committee for the last
careers what do you what do you want in
the way of the business plan so that you
know we can look out for this or ask for
this to come back to us what what what's
your idea of what you need for a
business plan
it's not like what my lab is planning is
it was an interesting to see what the
business plan that had been prepared by
this five building control was but yeah
but you can see it well with whether
they could argue that what they've
submitted here is their business playing
that's not what they argued in November
2017 sorry through the chest
it's the releasing November 2017 men
should mention the business plan as well
that's all it was so this is your
business plan effectively this is your
answer is it I would say based on that
that the the various committee reports
that have come forward have outlined our
approach to how the future service
should be delivered and those aspects
that we're going to be concentrating on
so in essence I guess it is a business
plan because it's looking at how we're
marketing ourselves how we're branding
ourselves how we're communicating how
we're going to recruit how we're going
to train future staff so as far as we're
concerned if you probably have all the
elements and essence of a business plan
even if it isn't sort of writ large so I
come back on that I'll just point out in
the minutes he did say in respective
business plan objectives which at the
meeting in November indicated following
on from questions that there was a
business plan that was all the business
plan has been outlined in them isn't it
on my computer POC yeah okay thank you
very much get some little control
sections in some authorities to produce
a business plan and I'm happy to take up
a suggestion and look at those with my
colleagues on the Essex Police
Association see what other people
produce I'm happy gonna be : thank you
very much
just as expansion about this business
plan I think what was being requested or
or discussed freely this meeting was
perhaps more on the financial on the
target target setting an achievement of
those targets to see if it's meeting
specific targets to make it a viable
project because what was mentioned
before was that in allowed building
control to get to a level where it
wasn't really going to be perhaps
contributing to to the council and the
overall council sort of like and it's
looking to have something like this
become something that was going to sort
of generate income into the council as
well as meeting it's pretty notice these
requirements of you know the function of
it would control but also to generate
something into this I think that's I
think that was the aspect really it come
on a call and generate more money for
the council because the fee that's
recovered kind of any it has to be cost
neutral for the customer so you can't
make a profit so the court generate any
cuts but what we can do though is
protect the council from having
additional costs by collecting as much
fear and keeping the market share by
yeah so that is really yeah so he must
have a reserve a 3d appearance of em
pays for those peaks and troughs
so that allows itself to be
self-sufficient in that degree there was
any one customers just have to maintain
the service and get many customers and
get such thing as possible it was the
danger that it could become a drying
wrong I mean I'd say the aspects of the
previous years you know it has met its
its budget over the last
but wasn't high mmm particularly the
question on what the race was in
relation to the recruitment aspect
obviously it's been identified over a
quite period of time there was a
requirement for staff and it was
obviously brought up and it was
highlighted in back in November I don't
see those very few maps between that
reporting now I understand that you're
looking to interview people tomorrow
easy is it the process of sort of like
trying to recruit the council process
was paused this lengthy delay widget
purely getting response from from people
to truly an advertisement for for the
positions or we had to go through a
process to get the market forces service
bar I mean that's that's the main thing
we tested the market previously and we
had been under able to recruit at the
salary level of a substantive salary
level even though we had that job
evaluated in this time period between
then and now to raise those salary
levels of substantive ones that we
tested that again that didn't work so
then the market supplement policy came
in in October 2017 we had to prepare a
business case and then that was with
planning and building control have that
signed off agreed
then how about business cases to recruit
agreed and then go out to the market
again to test that so there is there is
a number of protesters in that time and
and yes it has taken until now to be
able to achieve that so there's as taken
from OpCo October 2 now to
go from there hole yeah we valuation
process yeah well yeah and and and there
was the debate over what posts were able
to be recruited to or not at the same
time as that a state of interest is that
how does that compare is that a normal
procedure does it always take that long
to get to the position you in now it
depends what approaches some some some
councils have panels which then allow
the recruitment of somehow business
cases I think the case in point that
delayed this was getting the market
software in place and getting that right
in doing the benchmarking and
understanding at what salary level
hopefully would be able to recruit out
and getting some feedback from agencies
and recruiters in that process to make
sure that we were pitching ourselves at
the right level as well as having tested
that market prior to that to have the
evidence to demonstrate that a market
supplement should be applied to these
posts whose responsibility was that for
for the markets acumen that that fell
with me so okay but you are confident
now there are interviews taking place so
I assume you're confident that you want
people to get the right no we don't get
many applicants so there is an issue
yeah we don't get many applicants do you
ask the applicants and that's the same
with planning as well as building
control and we have asked the agencies
for feedback to obviously understand
whether it's salary location a
combination of the two or other factors
all the market and people don't want to
lose counsel because of the risk of
redundancies and it's better to have
been where you've been for a period of
time so there's a number of factors and
we're receiving feedback on that
information still at the moment but it's
a difficult market even with the
supplement and we're applying a
supplement but the issue is that others
are applying a supplement also or may
apply a supplement because we are
providing a supplement which puts us in
a difficult situation again because then
we compete
at a market that's a high level but
that's that's the market it's very
difficult and particularly when there's
so few out there to to recruit to the
posts even with a relocation fee which
has agreed as well so maybe to be able
to recruit officers from from other
parts of the country as well but it
hasn't proved that fruitful I don't
think you ought to come back on that
point just a very very question are you
interviewing multiple candidates was it
just an individual no tomorrow
we we did have two candidates for
tomorrow but one has dropped out so we
have one do you know we don't know at
this point unless Richard I don't know
she I will find out
yes we'll find out that mean episode it
was literally today no no this is the
situation which we face so it's very
difficult people will test the market
their own post by applying for the most
and then when the employer realizes that
they could possibilities then we had
better offer
yeah sure and I thought then why did it
taste in the elephants as the candidate
was recently locally iced I'm have you
dropped out in pregnancy
one last question I have in the people
you do make a statement air that regards
to the phone app and the online pointer
this has improved experience of
customers assessing the service how was
that measured that's quite confident
statement so this improved negative
measured by them in place or not okay
or there's particular issue complaint
before them but the number of plates
that have coming to me of late since
before I when I first started now drop
significantly if we related to building
control only because in mentioning
interest implications all-in-one let's
say there that this is led to heavily
prioritize and work according to risk of
non-compliance and questions making
complaints together faster mysteries it
has happened in the past and whether
that's a formal complaint or not that's
that's the difference I guess it as far
as formal complaints are concerned if
that has reduced but they complain first
of all the dentist's either can't get
through it on the button and then about
having the phone I think they say that's
much better rather than trying to phone
it so that's why you've got customer
experience is improved because they're
spending about feedback and saying gosh
I don't really please did open yeah cuz
that stopped me
I mean I worked out the Builder who made
Bank ten calls you know 10 or more calls
if you're spending forty minutes
he's lost a whole afternoons work of the
job you know so it's good anybody who
uses the app and they say it's a big
improvement
okay Thank You Chancellor mr. Shaw I
think you just one questions really
counts for how I've just come through
did November with you with the building
control and I can't find any mention at
all and that Julian Abbas really to skim
through it with me as well any mention
of a business plan so I wonder where we
got this business plan for all my
Germany from customers sure looks in the
millions your signature all right we're
looking at it and I'll be can't see it I
think
thank you very much and doctor prefer
Castor's if they want to let Kong show
you draw the recordings of the meetings
okay so by is it brief please you
mentioned about assessing the
improvements in the service from from
the level of complaints you receive is
that in any way all DT so big you can
beef up some way of reflecting light
over a given period of time
yeah we have a place to report it that
way we do yeah I guess you know we're
the officers who produce the performance
reports and other complaints we can look
back and see that level of formal
complaint that we gather and I think I'm
right in saying that when you get the
closure on the job either off of the
completion certificate thing the song
method of feedback at that point he
works as well in the correspondence I
mentioned it's about giving feedback
so he was involved in the process can
then give you some feedback in the whole
experiment is feedback I guess the other
element that Rich's been saying here is
that there has been positive feedback on
the job from from builders and others
who have used the app and have felt that
the processes have been proved over the
last 18 months I guess
there's something some authorities
though they do to the customer survey
most than you get back is that planning
on rebuilding control or so it doesn't
it doesn't always give you the
information you want another people just
tick satisfactory what you can do is you
can do it by phoning people and saying
you just go
can you tell me a little bit what worked
what didn't work and then you can record
that and talk about that but because
we're so we know we know we're not
performing look here was don't really
need that feedback to tell us we don't
don't get on a phone that would respond
Stalin said that I we know that so do we
improve that things put a little work
but thank you very much
remembers there's a recommendation there
which is to know protest phase and
implementing the new structure to
stabilize and improve that performance
of ability control service having heard
see now I believe there is progress
being made and I don't think it would be
constructive to bring this back again
during this municipal here because I
think the issues and problems have been
identified I think you probably needs a
bit of time to get somebody in get the
app and the payment system up and
working as best as it can and I think if
you would like to come back with an
update that's all I think of the members
would be grateful of that I don't know
how other members feels I'm not sure you
know this was raised in 2017 with
gratification said ie I don't know if we
need it back in this municipal year
again if any members think differently I
don't know members I'm happy to are you
happy to take over the recommendation
for a funky yeah okay I think that's a
great thank you very much taking video
to make it thank you
staying
[Music]
so nice nature giving them the it's a
brief report so I'll try and summarize
some of the big the key aspects of it as
chairman said it it pull it up from the
reporting in January and covers some key
areas that were requested at the last
meeting first time being arrest center
training for members we also provide an
update regarding in member
communications in an emergency the chain
of command and responsibilities through
an emergency and also last the
categorization of emergencies depending
on their severity in terms of the first
item member training it's probably worse
or if it's not in reports happen today
but probably worth mentioning that today
we also held some training for the
leader and deputy leader and the
chairman and vice chair regarding how to
deal with the media and you
of a large incidence building on
previous experiences around the country
of other large instances about how we
can actually learn from that about how
we can support members should they be in
front of the media dealing with
difficult questions so we provided some
information I think is very well
received and Jeff may cover that in his
in his update but yeah that happened
today
and was a positive step forward I feel
in terms of the approach to emergent
planning and business continuity we
we've had lined this report and in a
previous report and we've got some some
very simple but thorough procedures in
place now we've developed over a number
of months working with Jeff so they've
been developed and tested wand exercised
scenarios desktop exercises but also in
real-life scenarios without like
previously as well so we then feed back
from those review them and test them and
and then who's going forward to make
sure that that they are they are fit for
purpose just to draw your attention to
one item on the report there is an error
on section 4.3 it reads the leader will
deputy that if they are unavailable it
should read if they are available so
parties without that should read
available to draw attention to that but
the report is the state hopefully it's
clear and it provides information
members request in January myself well
Jeff happy to answer any questions
so I have a couple of questions I'll
just speaking in one section 5.0
organizations involved in the Emergency
Response multi-agency Strategic Command
Room or before the council ensure that
their representations of this group in
order to contribute to the setting
available strategic aims in to feed
information back to its emotional
emergency information Spencer
their multi-agency Strategic Command
Room is that something that's already in
place or exists or where all emergency
services of the council I've got a plan
as to how it was yes I mean that that's
sort of nationally accepted approach
some all counties so practice the sort
of concept of having a strategic
coordination group there's certainly
something in Essex that's been in
operation oh I know probably certainly
sort of 15 odd years so then there's a
well practice at it some of you may have
heard it referred to was the the goal
command so that was the sort of
terminology that was previously used but
as partners of updating terminology is
now referred to as strategic command
[Music]
yes do you think it would make an
appearance
yes I mean certainly the we would make
that that plan available it is a very
short plan it's it's not through
problems of size to take about three or
four pages which summarizes the approach
that we take so super become a nothing
championship after that if I may I'm
just trying to find in the report but
from the memory they get me Tehran
become memory I think referred to in the
previous report forgive me if I'm wrong
might think we refer to it in there
if not we can say we made that better
yeah but it's a very short it's attempt
to be short concise document enables us
to focus on the key issues and
considerations any event an emergency in
terms of business continuity
thank you thank you councillor mountain
thank you Jim just innovation to mediate
a few words just know who is the
training provider and which who was
trained yes the company that we chose we
looked at number of companies the
company we chose is mosaic which is
based in Colchester it's broadly led by
a very experienced journalist she's sort
of excellent BBC Essex
of BBC local newspapers all this sort of
thing and he actually came to do the the
train stay we did it in two sessions the
first one was aimed the morning session
was was was aimed at the bolita in the
chair and their deputies on the basis
that they are the people who were likely
to be approached as the spokesperson is
for the council so we ran through some
training from there and to make the
maximum use of over while she was here
in the afternoon when we run a similar
session but with four of the assistant
directors on the basic issues relating
to their services they don't tend to use
a color coding only in color coding that
I've seen used is the woman of relates
to the terrorist incidents and even that
is not something that they they used to
a great extent now so they don't tend to
use a color coding they tend to use the
sort of titles there to be clear so
they're just tired for so no yeah thank
you yes yeah it's interesting that that
the you've identified media training as
one of the key elements of of member
involvement and unaccountable
involvement is there any other areas
that you've identified might be useful
training for members not just those
at the top of the council and leader
deputy leader et cetera but also members
is there any possible other training
that on different aspects of emergency
planning that you're you're looking to
bring for all that sometimes yes we have
done as part of the general member
training we've done training in the past
on the general response approach the
District Council and how that links into
the member role and how that comes
together and we're certainly I mean
obviously with with changes members it
may be something that we should look to
to running again to to update those
who've not not taken part in that
training in the past and that's really
the key thing is it's of understanding
the response of the council and then how
that might link into to do your roles
and if there's anything that
particularly specific comes out of that
we complete that upset me and then jam
again just to add to that from a the
report 3.1 refers to one air of that
being a route rest center training so
that that will be picked up to another
where how members may be able to assist
the point is helping at those rest
centers in the event of a major moves
just don't touch on when they came to
help anyways they're many slots things
with you concede I think I'm whitey
remembering that quite important part of
that review was the fact that a lot of
members raised the fact that they
personally weren't trying and were
unaware of what to do in an emergency
and I've believed that that was one of
you one of the priorities that you were
going to go back with and that Mister
now I appreciate there has been an
election in between them so there are
new members but certainly four members
have been with Council even myself for
three years I received no training
whatsoever not just dominant media
training as to how I would deal with by
the media if it was an event in water
board or dealing with my constituents I
personally wouldn't know what to do
I had no training I have known briefing
notes and I believe that other members
that concern I think you've just quite
strongly put across that the members
were uncomfortable with that now I
appreciate the they obviously have been
some developments there's been some
trainings which you touched on today
especially with regards to media
training but I really do think the back
of the hook boys comments that that we
know needs to be given the priority
sorry because I'm chairman of standards
and I'm taking this on for what you said
because to do what you've just said it's
all what it's like a design and I feel
the councillors do need to know maybe
not as high office when I've even say
with yet obvious I have as if the
leaders etc and I think what I'm going
to do is I'm going to bring this to
spend as we've got a subcommittee which
we talking about training and I'm gonna
bring this up to it and I think this is
a good I think that we should be doing
in the training in the train station so
I will do that for you chairman if I may
in terms of general training over the
chair mentioned three years Sony Jeff's
run some member training but in what
time project was the last session around
that was relatively recent I've kept
thinking I'd take up wasn't spectacular
and so we would encourage to the next
one ferment all members are getting to
you know be to engage with that we have
run all member training sessions
[Music]
indeed not saying that the board shown
and certainly we have run that the
encourage members to attend there and
that gives our general approach some
specifics in to follow up but we have
run it in the past and certainly gonna
run that again and what came out the
last meeting was around so he was around
it in terms of member communication so I
picked that up and the report refers to
specific on the day there was talk of
rest center training and members
specifically could assist the rest
centers so that's the next things you've
brought forward after the media training
regard something like president
sentences I'm assuming that the council
already having twice
not this but I'm assuming you've
identified where those senses would be
yes really does the council engage with
the public direct to make the public
aware or educate the public what they
could do what actually should consider
in the event of a large event where
would they go if they got a list of
names just something that they can
possibly keep it home look brings about
I think probably a run where the
difficulty we get is is that the each
situation is so different than so
specific to to what's happened with a
lot of the decisions are made at the
time and they're made by the emergency
services because they're the people who
do some respond initially we work with
emergency services so so they're aware
of what our primary best centers as we
call them are but they may not
necessarily use those depending on the
circumstances they may feel it's better
to use something more local and we will
then look to support them within that so
it's very incident sort of specific if
we were to dispel sort of trying to
educate the public basically we get too
complicated this would be one if it's
this you go there if it's a go there if
the police tell you that then you would
do something different than what's the
part tell you something else so what we
tend to work is more generic plans where
we can make those decisions quickly and
then communicate those through to the
public so that they there's no because
it's been communicated out at the time
depending on the situation there's yeah
there's complete clarity as to what's
happened and it can't be what I thought
that was supposed to go there we'll do
this but do you think audio come inside
and I understand them do you not think
perhaps when you say use the term
engineering that there could be
generically instructions or guidance for
residents but just to give them
something to think about
pack a bag or have a bag ready if you've
got elderly or vulnerable residents
I appreciate that I think as a district
the chances of a catastrophic event
happening off probably less than other
parts of the country I understand that
but even if it's just if you informed
them the best centers may be set up I'm
asking you to specify well as your sense
baby if they're in their mind they think
there would be some way to go rather
than or ask them to make plans that they
could say somewhere else with a relative
or family I think they were probably
some instructions that could be quite
generic just to give them something to
think about here a little bit yes oh we
have got some information on that on our
website so that people do go into
doesn't have a look at that that is
available to them there is work going on
through the Essex resilience forum where
we all work together on areas of
emergency planning
so rather than the sort doing something
slightly different we're all doing the
same piece of work and sharing it which
is looking at community resilience as
they call it and it's trying to look at
ways that we can get some of these key
messages across to the public but we're
all finding it very difficult it's very
resource intensive to actually get out
to the public almost on an individual
basis so what we tend to do is pick it
up when we've got an opportunity where
there is a particular focus so the roof
there's a particular concern about a
risk or something like that then we will
go out and we talk to them and we go
through what the issues are so for
example I've been a sort of emergency
exercise a great Wakering to go through
issues there and we have about do them
in about 40 young people there who came
along for a great Wakering and we ran
through that all those sorts of issues
how it happens and so on so that's the
approach that we tend to take it's been
around where there is a demand and we've
got that support then yes we will go in
there and do that but we found
throughout the county to try and have it
in a generic way we're just not reaching
people in the right way
thinking they shouldn't be looking at
County we should be looking at our
district okay if there are lessons to be
learned from recent events which I won't
mention because I don't think the chance
of us having one of those particularly
top ten events happening here is slim
but one of the lessons we should learn
from that was that in the immediate
aftermath of that have been a confusion
with people that were you know lost
their homes they didn't know where to go
and who to contact what to do when you
find yourself homeless without any items
or personal possessions or missing
family members I just think perhaps we
could be doing more just pre educating
residents or just give them a bit of
confidence that it's something the
council their council has taken into
consideration that their council will be
there to assist them help where they can
and perhaps that message hasn't really
filtered through as councilor Weston you
know say I mean Essex County Council
that I mean I think they're probably one
of the biggest authorities granted any
like this a huge idea they would be the
first or examiner Michals with them when
I first the councilmen and again my only
concern is like my concern is two things
one we should I feel yes we need to
train to get an idea exactly what would
happen and there will be people than
there was years ago when we had a little
bit funny around here there was a four
or nothing there was typically Hudson
and people quite a few of them who was
there to help people eccentric spirit
down by the caravan science my only
concern is if we start trying to educate
residents you're going to get written as
getting a little bit concerned about
something it's gonna Michael may both
happen
will happen rather than an aspect just
sort of saying well if this does happen
it is what you need to do I think I've
got to be very careful where the
residents are concerned and they were
also we've also got something out there
that we would already turn in the
residence if anything have a bag packed
for an emergency an emergency which is
you Walter you told you whatever so more
less I mean that's what sort of you can
tell residents but I'll be a little bit
concerned with going and start a fencer
isn't if this happened you need to
contact some so they won't tell you what
to do I think we've got to be very nosy
fine line it's like you what we're
trying to do anything and trying to say
I think merely well not really travel
company and you know one of the things I
do know when there were strikes the
permanent petrol stripe switches and
they do only coming in and things like
that when I was always talking about
this emergency there we've got people
that come they stopped the schools but
he stopped going some people couldn't go
to what the potential doing had to be
looked after so they shut the schools
down because the buses they didn't allow
the buses to rest of fuel to take the
children in the schools so the schools
shut down there for their parents boom
car to work and fluid since we had some
done can see was done probably the
doggie factory and they said that they
don't get the staff so all their stuff
was getting spoiled everything
you know I mean it's all defrosting
because they didn't have to start to
locate them and get things back so there
is something
and now I'm Mike they because I've asked
travelled around ladies doing a school
contract you'll get the facts always
underneath the flyover you get floods
coming into windows from different areas
so you get a traffic jam anywhere and
I've seen that happen when you just
booked a route of somewhere that to get
around places one thing I do find that
when you say you're gonna talk to people
you need to talk to the business did you
know that they also even got those
emergency kind of emergency plan if I've
got that evening while I am well but no
I'm frightful in my district does well
mother said well officer
I've got back down and I know that
company's not supposed to have that done
and they're not told that these people
have been up in factories the schools
nothing and the carrots will think about
remember that when I still think that
shuts comments down because people can't
buzz people around all these people are
trained maybe for the media or training
for emergency services might something
not yet to come to work because they
can't go in because they can't get the
fuel they've got to look after their
children so there'll be less people even
to like communicate with other people
because it involves so many something
the businesses people need to talk to
their enjoys to find out what they can
what everybody does but I don't you know
that it's not many lynnium and they have
a beautiful attraction are finding
before the event that's what I have
completely telling individual people you
know so I do you think it's businesses
that need to know about this and
emergency planning is telling to to move
people even in
I didn't assume I've just become part of
urban situation as it affects or
committee member there's less vehicles
now for the shortage of drivers to
transport people so you need to look at
that size as well okay now thank you
very much I get impressed I think
basically it's encouragement from the
council to businesses to thank you very
much thank you hearing the offices will
make a note that I'm sure and I'm
looking right at if I could just get
back to some people were council wait
thank you Jim just a couple of things
please how do you feed do you get
feedback from parish councils or town
councils business and emergency plans on
the way whole bridge is currently doing
theirs and how do they feed into the
overall emergency plan for Easter yes I
do be around then I think now to all the
parish meetings at least ones and we do
talk through I do encourage them to do
their own emergency plans and to share
with with me so I've got that key thing
that we look at really is is the contact
side of things so it should something
happen we can talk to each other again
parish is a vitals they're the people
who were there on the ground they're the
ones that are seeing it first they're
the ones that got the really local
knowledge
so yes work very closely with them as
did the district councils obviously
applicable knowledge yeah just on the
other point about adviser good crossing
it's obviously the emergencies about
emergencies about reaction to it largely
I think the problem is there unforeseen
that's very hard to plan for I'm wearing
hold which is probably quite wide agree
as well the the main danger people are
unaware of is flooding
and they're very well-rehearsed in what
to do that they have the phone warning
so they're aware what to do so the most
like he took me affected in the most
likely event are aware what they need to
do and they do get the text alerts or
the flood warnings by phone in those
areas which are a problem in otherwise I
put up a new trial and everybody about
everything that's virtually impossible
and that then moves on to they see it's
quite clear about what goes on in a in
an ordered way but my concern and
Jenny's and I'm sorry I'm gratified to
Kenzie and Chelsea's it was that we are
a very small Authority and my concern is
that something will happen and it gets
beyond our ability very quickly and we
fail to recognize it that's not really
dealt with in here how is this seems
that you can automatically into the
county area or even into spring energy
it would be what's going on
click scene but it might not be that it
doesn't have to be that big in my view
in this district to be on no doubt about
the drop and I wondered how we had a
vague that and a central government say
if I was coming first and gently pick up
and certainly the learning for example
of cancer that we mentioned was that yes
it phenomenally resource heavy it will
consume your communications team or
leadership team your members and most of
your authorities something's that size
and that that's certainly lonely came
out of that if you didn't know already
Hussein to now so Jeff sorry done work
previously through is leisure team and
others looking how I've increased the
resilience in communications team and
the other key areas and how we look to
share that resilience with photos
evening about in terms of short shoots
around around the start based on your
authority we have to be mindful of that
and then make sure that in those key
areas like indications we can increase
that resilience where possible so we can
train up other members of staff to
assist with the communications team
because it will absolutely just consume
the only station that was to happen
Jeff's not some further work I'm sure
Jeff will come in and take yes
and me again going back to the Essex
resilience forum them as a forum where
we get together to to sort of work
jointly one of the key things were
looking at is mutual aid the same but
all the local authorities and also the
emergency services finding great
difficulty with sufficient resources so
we have to help each other and we do an
extensive amount of work I mean for
example on Thursday I'm meeting with the
Essex housing officers group to look at
issues around the rehousing of large
numbers of people who may be displaced
by an emergency because no single local
authority has got sufficient available
housing to to look after them so it's
something that we've we've got to do as
a as a group within the county or even
across County so yes I agree entirely
with what you're saying and it is
something that we're looking at to how
we can increase our resources just one
further mission based on it when you
refer to the county of Essex obviously
we have two counties Eve one is the
geographical county one is the political
county when you're talking about the
county of Essex are you including South
Indian there are they part of that was
obvious get and nearest envious
neighborhood I hope you to
does include tharok and and Southend or
something as you quite rightly say South
End is is because of its geographical
proximity and this resource is something
that we've got primarily towards thank
you very much councillor Quinn Thank You
chairman all the things were probably
gonna cover some of the something that
the hallways already mentioned that it
was the parishes have their own
emergency planning
and I have been involved with great
white creams emergency planning but also
you've been too busy seeing you send you
a number of other parishes as well but
I've had the benefit of being a parish
council have being able to see and have
some involvement in there but obviously
if you're not from one of the local
parishes or you don't have that nothing
that's probably what that Chairman was
speaking about in you don't get to see
some of the more detailed aspects of the
emergency planning side of it at that
local level and that's probably where
the the training aspect would be much
more beneficial for the broader members
of this council and oops I pick up on a
point that counsel was mentioned about
the fact that we are a relatively small
Authority but we do have fair coverage
of the land area but we also have
another key item just within the within
the district which is is there a snare
port and if there wasn't an emergency
relating to the airport that possibly
something that would be far beyond the
ability of the council to deal with if
it was a major event a terrible I would
imagine that there's a whole range of
different structures deal with something
like that yeah
do you thing at you the last meeting we
talked about in some detail to do with
it you have highlighted do you had do
you like that yes possibly being the
biggest where the divisor is a key risk
clearly and and the ejector picks up
throughout other networks and training
and exercises have been run out the
airport and testing those scenarios and
a response again they have their own
internal resort things and everything
yes there is an emergency planning group
especially for already the airport which
is a multi-agency group emergency
services its ourselves its South End and
obviously the airport that stars
themselves STOBAR so yes plans there are
really quite well advanced thank you
Thank You councillor Wilson that's a ten
point there's also in cases where funds
need to be made available quickly the
when you look at the identity operation
there's assistant director level well
that should be involved in some Newlands
disaster recovery situations and we had
in our business continuity plan was
relatively junior officers authorized to
spend money in the business continuity
that the reason why I say that the
babysit there is something on fire
service we have generally we have a
supportive previously a system of all
officers 24/7 available they have
authority for smaller all down for a
corporate credit card if necessary out
of hours they don't have contact through
again 24/7 access to an on-call GTA V
who can authorize great to spend if
necessary sir as there is a system in
place you need to do
thank you calves are good in did you
know the members of all staff are
trained in emergency procedures like
counsellors cos wanna see if there's an
emergency and we're asked to participate
and help could we not put those members
who are trying to help in danger because
unless we've been trained how do we know
what is dangerous and where is not
dangerous and we could be putting them
in worse danger by being ignorant to the
fact rather than mean sufficiently
trained to know where and what not to do
typically fire you know you might not
say to people friend down there and
they're not sports are supposed to walk
down there and obviously in emergencies
things can happen so I think personally
if we're gonna go through with my
business evacuation at least the staff
and council counselors should be trained
I think in terms of member training
what's going to take that away chairman
and I think that the memory training is
broader it's not sticking around at an
evacuation point it will be the the
bigger picture starts really between
sounds of staff training
Jeff's per to offer to all staff to
attend processions around how
would deal with emergency and their role
within that yeah okay thank you very
much
yep just a few uh South in Council have
got an actual building but for a drop of
a hat and they had to do it over
Christmas they could open up with okay
they've got they'd say and it's
everything so if you've got an emergency
for one of our old people's places they
can get them out
I'm talking straight in and that's what
happened uh period detail but the blacks
determine that that's regarding the
emergency there a number of those
established we could set up depending on
the location severity and speed we do
have some equipment in place and Jeff
mention the wide approach you looking to
take on and not severe my actual kid we
have it's limited but we do have some
access right thank you mutual aid if it
was bigger because we'd have a small
amount of it yeah I mean just to answer
that very quickly the the key thing is
is we've agreed between all the district
councils and the two you have to be
authorities to follow the same
procedures and to keep the same kid so
it just makes mutual aid that much
easier because we're all working the
same way we can go to any authority and
ethicist and we can bring our kit and
it's exactly the same as everybody
else's thank you thank you very much
we've members his recommendation
the contents of the report they
collectively we could cover quite a lot
than your last Butler professional
athlete
look this is will take back quite quite
a lot of feedback at members are happy -
yeah
moving on to their new constitution as
you know members will know and newer
members there is a working party which
have been set up to review the
Constitution with assistance the latest
report is an update on where the project
is along with some proposed changes to
the Constitution as if you could kind of
go over it just summarize that don't
expect you to point out interesting to
me it's all very clean for members to
see yes thank you Joe I think you
summarized it quite well that I mean the
picks up now again and we've met
we are starts to meet more frequently
and this report here is the work we've
done so far there is another report
coming forward this month there's
another report coming for next month
because there's a bit more work than
what's in here I've tried to make it as
easy for members to understand what
changes are by creating this table as I
did previously on page 8.4 onwards just
to show you what the current situation
is what the recommended changing the
reasons behind those changes and I'm
happy to take questions on on any issues
there or concerns or any clarification
cancel me thank you
or the safety fair review committee
meetings the chairman of the review
committee will be drawn from among the
opposition counselors what about the
nomination for chairman of the review
committee is that is it is it clear that
the the Chairman should be nominated 5
your position I believe the nominations
come forward from each group or each
policy and new council you nominate your
your members who decodes the community
and the nominees Chairman's and it's
voted on an annual calendar I thought I
thought of this and this is nothing this
is just an observation of what happens
but there has been a situation where the
Chairman has been nominated by the
administration yes that's correct
I should that no should it not be in
terms of if it is for an opposition
councilor that the nominated chairman
should come from the opposition that is
one of the members did you sort tonight
do just that I think it's quite clear
the chamber the view committee will be
drawn from among the opposition I don't
think there's any debate in question it
shouldn't be or should it the the
administration who nominate the
opposition member to do review committee
or should it come from the opposition
members to nominate your chair
of chairmanship II you know as I read
the opposition to put through accounts
at the nomination and the administration
puts remedies it's decided to a council
and voted upon there's nothing in
legislation to say it has to come from
the opposition party understanding I
think the review is to review what
happens through the administration's
that you've got the legal party the
review committee reviews decisions that
are made recordings if to ensure that it
is completely has a completely objective
approach sure the chairman should be
denominated person to the Chairman
should not she should come from the
opposition members not from the
administration I think opinion it is a
belief but I can't see that there would
be any opposition to that belief in
ensuring transparency that that is the
role of the review committee is to make
sure for the administration can be
fairly challenged and not have somebody
appointed by the administration to chair
this really that's all I'm saying is
that it should be the opposition would
nominate somebody and if that
the input Council but the nominations
should come from the opposition and not
for the administration I'm happy to
check on that if that was a motion to
put forward oh yeah yes about it I
understand the point being made at the
moment it can look like the chair of the
review committees appointed by the
administration as he stands and all the
way it works and I understand it's much
better than that but he's in the case I
would like I was selling another class
of motion I would hope that in the no
one would oppose that Nucky's shortly
this is the whole purpose of you if this
is going to be voted on the road well I
think the purpose of reviewing as you've
correctly pointed out is to review the
work that is undertaken by the Council
for science chairman that's covered to
obtain counsel I would add the process
we have in place there there's nothing
in statute to say it has to come from
the opposition this council has chosen
that the chairman of review will come
from the opposition there's nothing
wrong with that legally angela andrews
right it's always been that the review
chairman is an opposition from the
administration as you're saying it's
just that your issues the admission
administration choose to put put
somebody from your position into that
position what you're saying is the
administration should have nothing
whatsoever to do with it we can't do
that that's not that is that's not we're
not being the correct way to do I
understand what you're saying no but
sorry you right - sir I am saying the
nothing to do with the nomination it
should still be voted off by four
council I'm not disputing that okay
remember we are talking now to a motion
because you have formed a new second a
bit before it goes to actually cancel
points personally think your parents
although you know I know that other
councils have as you say this may not be
so that Soph like something that's
legally bound on on individual councils
but I do know that other councils follow
a tradition which is the wise that's
been set out by councillor mountain in
that it's for the opposition to to
nominate someone and it's generous that
that person who is who's appointed by
the opposition is insert he's approved
he can also obviously if it come to a
vote in council it could be very sit
down but that that's I know that that is
the way that it happens in in a number
of other councils around comes to finger
off the top of my head now because I
have I knew this may be an issue I was
expected to speak on I have looked in
depth into that with music and they drew
councils and
one where the current opposition having
a position to elect but you can't
nominate because the opposition can't
nominate that that's an issue with
respect we know it's never gonna if the
administration nominate from your
position it's a majority isn't it so if
the administration nominate somebody
then the nature of the majority is that
now is the person that will be
nominating whereas it should be that the
opposition the sort and the opposition
would nominate maybe two people two
opposition words and then forecast
really should not be able to the
opposite of the the administration to
nominate good chair oh sure that's clear
forward councillors pairing yeah
any group as far as I understand could
nominate whoever they want what you're
asking is the biggest group be excluded
from the nomination process right and
that's right sorry we administration is
the largest majority it represents the
largest percentage of the population and
therefore the minority is trying to
overthrow the majority now if the
opposition groups nominate two
candidates and the majority group don't
want either of them where'd we go then
other clauses would come in I suppose so
why do you need other clauses always you
can do these just say as we quite
rightly say now any group can nominate a
candidate
potential candidate as chairman of the
review committee and it will be voted on
that's it as far as I'm aware this
review committee is not here as on a
political basis we are here to question
decisions made by the administration and
to make sure to the decisions that are
made are justifiable that are correct
and that we are I think they call it the
constructive friend whatever pretty
critical friend and that's what we're
here to do I don't think any of the
conservative counts are sitting here I'm
going to just railroad something through
that could jeopardize the well-being of
this council and therefore the fact of
them we as the administrator nominate
someone
but that doesn't mean to say that we're
good enough I wholeheartedly agree with
a big decision the administration might
we're here to make sure that the
decisions recommended or made by council
are questioned and questioned fully and
to to eliminate sight that we as a
majority administration or whichever
group the largest group can't nominate
someone doesn't seem very democratic to
me somehow diverging okay concert worse
things yeah I'll take issue that you
have the largest percentage perhaps
given the fact of the regime we work
under a first-past-the-post
but we leave that as opposition parties
we can't nominate chairman to any other
committee at all that's the only one we
can nominate to so we don't think that's
much of an argument all these older
customers is saying with this motion is
that these sakes Wayne
anybody's saying that the Chairman's at
the pointing which it can look like I
think the Chairman he in this case is
independent only anyone else a different
how every is the look of it is the thing
and I think my administration nominate
someone it means they will be voting for
it it's an appointment they have the
majority they nominate someone who you
supposed to be scrutinizing the
administration and that's what it looks
like and that's marketing promotions or
each one it doesn't stop the
administration voting and perhaps it
will vote until there's a mutual
mutually like on candidate I don't know
but that's that's the point of view it
doesn't say where the vote of the
illustration it gives the opposition the
right to nominate to one chairman
[ __ ] whereas the administration and
nominate and will nominate to all other
chairmanships and vice-chair of the
shoes talking to emotionally afford and
seconded yeah I believe that is a matter
of perception outside of this room
outside of Council but in the wider
public as well if it is part of the
Constitution that the chairmanship of
review goes to a member of the
opposition I feel that perhaps the way
that it should be is that the nominee
the opposition nominate someone for that
role and that that individual is voted
on first
if that person isn't approved then there
are other other possible combinations
that could then be put forward could
then be voted on that's all part of the
perhaps making you a little bit of
mention we are talking to a specific
emotional forward so no I do agree that
perhaps the perception that at the
moment is that the individual who's put
forward talking about yourself but as an
individual put forward for this position
of chairmanship of the review can can be
deemed and viewed in the wider community
has an appointee of the administration
and not necessarily someone from the
from the opposition group who is meant
to oversee the review of councilor
Business Council of whiskey I'm meant to
believe that full council if your
position wants you to at that point in
time put someone forward actual counsel
you can do that anyway you haven't got
to wait you haven't got to wait for us
to decide off the administration saying
well we want to put this opposition
first in there you came and a full
council and say I'd like to nominate
somebody did something I just come back
on on it covers both up and cassis
bearings
I think Casa Hawaii made it extremely
clear from where I said that there was
the difference between appointee and
democracy and that is that if the point
of the nominee comes from the
administration and the very nature that
they are the administration means that
they would win the vote okay which has
the perception or with being a nominate
an appointee if the nomination comes
from the opposition then it's democratic
because you can choose between
candidates that have been
forward by the opposition not by the
administration everyone votes that's
democracy but if you have the
administration putting someone forward
it has the perception of being an
appointee because that is the person
that will be voted in so can you just
repeat remembers what the motion the
motion is the the wording within here
should be changed so that the chairman
that the nominee for chairman of the
review committee should be put forward
only by the opposition Council and that
seconded by Councillor mr. white yes
okay so if we could take a boat those in
favor of the motion to put forward by
Councillor Mountain best for please
could I have a record airboats wing you
should mention that
now you mentioned that as the vote is
taken
I didn't ask for a recorded vote said I
won't get my vote recorded for those
against
so we go back to content of their fault
if we had any other questions
God even wonder of what we have just
discussed other changes or inclusions
within cancer Britain under Chairman the
function that just went out on I think
that's going to be or it could have been
a permanent change I think it needs a
broader discussion outside of the
limited spending everything all the
review committees doing is making a
recommendation for Council
so on if that motion had been carrying
it would then go into full council had
enough other yep
so it all your do tonight is making a
recommendation for council all of these
changes okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there are a few words in there it's
compulsory topics that have to be
discovered throughout the year and they
already put into place onto the work
plan there are a few other words of
their books specifically free in the
agenda which have come forward which we
can discuss evenings meeting my androids
are Paul just for a moment a few
pictures you
yes yes right
compulsory items will be the Treasury
the three treasury management reports
have the annual review at the July
meeting Community Safety Partnership
because the overview is very community
review me is the designated comedian and
for the overview of crime and then also
the regulations of investigating three
powers at 2000 every year we come back
to members to tell you about the use of
those powers
this year we have been inspected by the
agency now is since inspection of
something that way China it halfway
through here that's my issue if you
remember seen going into the company in
Cambridge and Whitaker they were ready
on the back of their jackets but anyway
they have inspected us they're made a
couple of comments nothing that drastic
but we've had to draw up a social media
policy they took that so that will be
coming to members in October and that's
about it
relax repeat the second item Community
Safety partnerships is all relative
thank you
they'll come twice a year we only twice
that it would be usually the police with
their communities and safety hardship
representative cantaloupe is good there
was a proposal some time ago we've
received a report and I can't bring them
but was it directly University or
something we're going to ask the older
to come until the voice of the counselor
that's an ongoing project that there's
like there's three project groups at the
moment one on the Constitution one on
the voice that the cancer and one on i.t
cell and those groups already formed and
a meeting when we get to methodology
that was what was being asked for me
because certain members there on those
groups non review anymore do they need
replacing or will they be okay for them
to continue to come to those meetings so
come on to their dream and the next
agenda that's okay okay okay it topics
they're on the agenda own the first one
section one by one officer contract with
Essex County Council this is a
suggestion made from a member or maybe
more than one member and I don't know
who the specifics of it I don't usually
all we've had so far so I can't really
advise you on what it was that why that
was being brought forward
comments on that no I mean I think we
need to know what the question is I mean
you know there's a whole multitude of
issues that could go around this you
know should we have a contract with it
somebody from Essex County Council
should we have our own one five one
officer I mean this is the part of it as
far as I can see
but know if somebody's suggested this
German I suggest they in that break on
what they what aspect of this they want
to discuss you know you would obviously
encourage all members to nominate topics
or areas that they are interested in or
the belief that really the review
committee should be investigating and
obviously as a committee to decide
whether or not we move forward with that
sometimes when you're giving limited
information is quite difficult to make a
decision when you're not quite sure what
the objective is or what partner we meet
you're looking at so at the moment I
don't really feel we can commit to that
purely on the basis that we just don't
have enough information as to what is
what is what objective it or what the
objective is counsel I think possibly on
the back of what counts as Baroness and
it could be it could be a question or it
could be a multitude of questions about
the whole process of process of the
contract
it could be that the member or members
of phrase that I'm here to to give us
any inflation so we could obviously
bring it up first 78 said the next
meeting yeah possibly yeah yeah
castle branek chairman it was possibly
around the fact that we had such a high
turnover of offices was it for different
people with space of two years in the
three years right it could be or it
could be a factor that takes in all of
those companies with we really don't
know them so I'm not saying I'm not
dismissing it by no means but I just
think tonigh it would be very difficult
for us to commit to that and putting it
on the work plan we're not quite sure
what it why it was put forward in the
first place good yeah council Lukas kill
I've got a feeling that the current one
by one officers contract runs out in
September perhaps that's why it's being
listed possibly yeah Bank of it or they
can it could be you just sold it out
that could be one of them the fact it's
moving it's just not clear count some
you see sure I'm I think we can discuss
it further until the next meeting until
we actually know which members put it
forward and actually tell us exactly
what they want to know I don't think I
think we're wasting time discussing this
at the moment
that's the general consensus we'll move
on to the next item which is enforcement
of dog fouling
yes okay this has come forward from a
member I believe that um isn't here this
evening I'm not quite sure I mean it
says the enforcement of dog fouling
again it's done
inside it clear what is just being asked
counsel is there am something set up
with a sort of like fine findings or for
scheme the penalties for for this you
know it's a part of policy of the
council heads is it yeah I believe there
is yes so it's about whether that is
actually being enforced in these data is
there resources available to to
investigate this wants to put forward
and suggest that involve is we can
consider it this evening I was getting
personally to say it may be this or was
he that hot you say there's a policy in
place in place for a few years now and
also to fault it you've gotta catch the
person doing it back to the previous
comment I think we discuss this until we
know the Excite Nitra office enforcement
the dog fouling means a lot in the broad
scale we can't discuss it the person
remembers not here I think any of these
when they're members not here we cannot
discuss it because we can't free of the
questions
okay it was a Ricci nominate by cancer
nope obviously yeah
it's again something that came up and I
think it was along the lines of the fact
that they proposed that perhaps the
change to the current arrangement
committee wasn't working as well as
previously elected councillor yeah well
in this unless another council wants to
be that bright on that for a few then
the other councillors feel that that's
an item that's one of the other and can
I make this tight what wants to revisit
it at another time
once they've given it some more thought
then that's absolutely fine I think
there's an argument to say that the now
that the that particular committees been
operating for a period of time its
potential to look at it and review and
how it operates and how well it's
working so they might be I think this
I've had conversations and a couple of
other councillors who've had views as to
whether they felt oops
whether it was working as well as it
could do or previously so I think maybe
if you speak to those yes something's I
think there may be Austin
I think I think there's a possibility
that the another counselor will will
pick up pick this one up and and maybe
elaborate a little bit more again he's
probably going to be at the next meeting
before we get any meat on the other
stitches which have come forward from
other members in the meantime housing
and homeless strategy this has been for
seven members that have been on the
committee for why this what's the style
compulsory item that comes up every year
that's our hats generally appeared on
the schedule for the last two years but
there is a consultation between July and
September of the new strategy of the
committee I want to do that then
September would probably be a better
better time for one I don't know if
anyone else wants to comment on that
counties September would be a good long
because after um things quite down
around August time so yeah I think
September would be a good if you do it
in September October probably September
there's a good time if the consultations
out from July to September the officer
will be able to give you some feedback
on and the responses
yes relation for the first couple of
months and then it'll be fresh
yeah be a refreshing be able to give you
some more meat on the bone for the
strategy before she finally completes
her strategy
yeah I'm gonna give you a chance to add
input yeah
counselor man team I was gonna say he's
going back briefly
and the other ones on here is it
possible with the whoever has put these
forward he's invited to the next review
meeting if they're not they don't attack
and they they are removed from the
another suggestion that is it
specifically yes the NHS in particular
the join Clinical Commissioning group
and the STP the success regime I suppose
you call it as I've knew this one that's
suggested I've been doing a little bit
of digging Southend Essex and tharok
have established a statutory joint
committee health awareness and look at
this merger proposals as they call it
had a meeting on the 6th of June and
have called their terms of reference for
anybody interested they are already on
the south end website on the meeting of
the joint health scrutiny committee they
was also a presentation at the time from
the CCG and STP and I copy that that I
can send out links to that where I'm
leading up to is I'm advised that the
STP joined CCG are going to make a
decision on the consultation because the
consultation fee needed mulch and they
he then took independent there was an
independent review of the consultation
that was fed back to them but on the 6th
of July meeting in battle Dhin I'm told
it's a public meeting at the moment I
can't find out where that meeting is my
contact doesn't know and I can't tell
you the time either because my contact
doesn't know but they have asked the
same questions my contact with being
more obvious it number of South a you
know provide movie will be animation but
all this information republic it's
available there the public
[Music]
if we have if this goes on on to the
agenda for the review committee would it
be appropriate to ask a spokesman a
spokesperson from the joint South in
Furyk and Essex because they set up
something they must have someone who is
going to be appointed as a spokesperson
would it be appropriate to invite them
to one of their meetings when this built
up so that they could give a slightly
different perspective and what might be
coming out of the depends on what you
were asking them to come for what you're
talking about is one of the committee
members from the yeah their chairman my
counsel because I guess obviously if we
have the people from the success regime
where we will get a perspective from
there and it's the opportunity perhaps a
slightly different perspective from from
them from that joint group because
they'll they'll be looking at it from a
slightly different angle yeah I have to
be honest I think if you invite
something the success regime or I invite
something the succession
I don't think that come then they found
that an exclusion of the County Council
glass done they had another meeting if
they're going to make an incision on the
secret of you going yeah it's yeah you
don't have the 3rd of July another think
that they gonna conquer um
as for the members on that committee
Kemp's alumni's one of the Memphis good
of I can see over on in the sample and I
can certainly speak to my opposite
number sounding and see if we can get
the chairman to come and talk I think
can I just throw this one in what are we
reviewing as a review committee here
which is not be better for the whole
council to have the opportunity to ask
the questions if we can never get
anybody along a going to even if we call
a special meeting like we've done in the
past rather than a review committee
where there's 12 of us okay if we want
if we feel strongly enough about this
then as a full council we ask them to
come along like we did before and the
whole council discuss the situation
because I guess at the moment there's
nothing really for us to review that the
council is involved with we the district
council has made these decisions it's
it's make very clear it starts on all
this position and I think we've got
anything to review on what the council's
done but the council may want to review
what the whole process is is creating
council - so I think us got a broadly
table turn council experiment so I'm not
sure it's based on what we were actually
reviewing I'll shoot me
with how it would affect residents in
yeah Roger district and appliquéd I'm
not sure that the last four council
meeting given how he ended up with the
way the motions were there were in any
quick twelve questions even we weren't
able to ask questions because of the way
the motions were part unfortunately I
think it might be his council sparing
setting full council possibly and
Bernanke's recommendation week report to
the review committee could like that
recommendation
yeah I think really we're reviewing the
consultation and the outcome of it
because although there was supposed to
be an independent review of the
consultation there was a marginal amount
of participation so therefore that 3% or
whether it was actually participate it
doesn't really reflect the majority of
the residents in the area would you not
want to read what the committee said to
the hospital people
I've set number of senator says in
response to the consultation that
committee said the joint health overview
and scrutiny committee did not think it
was helpful announcing the Trust's
merger proposals during the consultation
that this could give the appearance of
hiding a very important issue the joint
health overview and scrutiny committee
would want to understand the
implications for any future service
reconfiguration and has concerns about
the impact and timing of the merger
commented it would perhaps you better to
maybe make a suggestion or
recommendation to to Council that we
might then lodge attend to for council
in session not so much a review of where
the question is an answer session which
would be more the basis here people I
have a presentation informing members
hopefully we would get some questions
and answers and just in general rather
than scrutiny of it has also the
recommendation would appears I'm sure
okay it's a good II would agree this is
gonna agree that perhaps other
viewpoints should also be invited yeah
yeah
cuz I think sometimes we just hear from
one of you wouldn't Asians and my
suggestion for my hamster would seek to
find if the chairman of the Joint
Committee might be interested in
participating on such an event okay any
other members have got any other
suggestions they will try the raisin
this evening more in the future than
please feel free
have come up which I briefly discussed
issues with how layaway line that goes
through the district the ongoing works
the delays lack of compensation this
came at time actually I did see that our
MP had sat down with a penny on its to
discuss it so that could be something
that the committee may want to consider
an update on the proposed closure of the
recycling center railing look and the
opening of the new one which kind of was
earmarked for which means farm that's
quiet there hasn't really been anything
said about it for a while is it worth
revisiting and asking whether or not
those plans are still valid something
that came up off the back of the review
training session with some members was
perhaps a look at how the removal of
payment machines has impacted residents
from the council offices but that can
now came up after training turn
cancerous a short thank you online I've
actually had one meeting with
the offices and I'm having another one
are they in their arms so if we could
not have anything until maybe all the
final figures they've said to me weren't
coming yet and of how it's worked at how
many people there's eighteen percent
that still need to go on but so I do
think about September time okay do you
think are you saying that you would be
able to come back to the committee with
some conversation when they begin to die
of all the street names where those
things are now you people use it I'm
just trying to find the light speakers I
mean I think also I don't know it's an
item that probably does need to be
keeping a bit of time to give a
realistic view of how those changes have
impacted so if members are in agreement
it may be a suggestion that we fight to
get verbal report from counselor mrs.
Shah first and then decide whether or
not that's something we want to review
that there's this two aspects of this
there's an assessment as to the impact
which we need to do but there's also a
requirement for those individuals who
find themselves not being able to make
payments in a normal way and is that
there hasn't been sufficient information
circulating about how they go about
making payments that they that they
can't do in their normal way and I don't
think that there's been sufficient
circulation of information about that so
the review aspects of it I think there
is an element of time requirement but
the information side of it is something
which is much more
for individuals out and wider community
which might be more important because
they they live in a position where they
they need to know how they're going to
go about making their normal payments
that's been out on the New York
what Judy's got there which I'm the one
they're all this counts the reception
staff are giving these out there helping
them full phones in there is a computer
in downstairs so they can actually make
a payment with a direct debit we do know
there are people that don't have
standard bank accounts but they can go
in and paid by the post office they can
go by paid by Building Society
I've checked all this out I've taken
residency on individual ones the
resident Baines Department will come out
and help every single person and I've
been there and I've taken them in and
out took one word 18 when I had a
meeting and I didn't even let them know
I was taking a ring and they done it
within seconds for I think what's
victory up she walked out and walk back
in I'm finished and that was how quick
is so they are really working hard I
appreciate we might not realize it was
happening but there was leaflets out
there and they say Julie's got them
there I don't I don't want to go into
this either one to put it I don't mean I
don't also want you to feel that all of
it no but I do think perhaps the way
forward is for council short to continue
as it she's at the moment perhaps if any
other members of review committee have
got any specific questions these three
questions are awesome if we can email
cancer showing the first incident we'll
get verbal report back from counselor
mrs. Shaw and then as a review committee
will consider what we advised and
whether or not we want to take that
further if the hall members are happy
that
you're comfortable with I want yes if
members are unhappy about them with that
anyone any comments on the railway issue
or the recycling center sorry we can't
attract each other
the recent some review of the fair Glen
interchange and the public consultation
I sense a quite lengthy letter to
various parties because my board
actually quite a fete chunk of it was in
the fair blend area and I've received no
requires whatsoever I think is that
smooth because they listen to the
council as a County Council a six may
accept looks like the exception and I've
highlighted the situation which means
from and the problems have been ongoing
for about 40 years
but I've received negative replies
contact your county councillor they all
include you Jason
seriously okay
did you email County Council all of the
ones are not referred District Council
[Music]
they're obviously there are some topics
then we've said we'll discuss those they
too
when the members that proposed them are
here there were some other ones that big
ones there like a big fairways and we
cite concerns which at the moment nobody
has any comments on so perhaps it might
be an idea but this overwork program on
the next agenda as well just to revisit
it get any further comments remembers or
feedback he made was a bit more time to
come up any topics that they wish to be
discussed yep okay thank you very much
Jim that item number 10 which is
methodology to discuss the degree
fundamental methods of operation to
achieve the work program specifically
the identification of project teams I
hand I was appalled he has already
touched on this this evening zone yeah
okay as I said earlier there's three
project teams at the moment on the go
that's the ITC the voice of the
counselor and the Constitution now
obviously there's a couple of members
that have come off the committee
counselor Dre's already indicated is
happy to continue on the review of the
Constitution which is probably a
sensible way because he's been there
since the inception rather than someone
coming cold they just continue on ITC
Bob mill kept my counselor Bob Filner's
indicated is still interested in that
one and that's been an ongoing one as
well the only other one is voice of the
counselor we've had a scope in meeting
the next meeting is on the 21st of June
which will be to look at the first
section of the report so cancel my on
resort work on that one and counselor
lovely if there are other members that
want to go on that one
yeah yes
going back to the ITC one obviously you
know me seen their member on there you
had a particular expertise in that field
have we got is there anyone whose girl
be a possible replacement for someone
you've got there anything like that
expertise in the area remember sitting
next to is already on that employ I
circulate you do this work is it is it
possible I don't it's a bit shaken that
I'm actually worked
I imagine
like that makes is only point can be
rescheduled I mean has cancer Newport
been asked think it's probably because I
I messed up didn't I love it I've messed
up I didn't send the a man I thought I
had no how about you Kamsa Stanley asked
me to resend it and then I found I
couldn't find the original so yeah
that's not a problem I couldn't open men
or women you know so I'm not available
but if it's okay to move it yeah just
for whatever is that particular project
down the line well the end a insight I
suppose is once we have moved to office
365 and the cloud completely from what
I've seen October might be there any day
yeah yeah why should we have something
to enter in we did in April there Ben
was it uncle yet the interim yeah yeah
give me between now and yeah no not ever
yeah I mean this seems to me to be one
that these projects we've got within the
council at the moment
we need to know what's going on already
imagine it'll probably get discussed at
the next investment or maybe take down
the dashboard yeah I mean once the next
what's gonna be 26th of June I'm going
to move in but potentially the best
wings in and out initially was working
this party will be able to buy yeah I
mean there's no reason why the group
couldn't well once once the group of men
I can circulate the minutes to everybody
yeah we did this yes yeah so I could
circulate all the minutes from that
meeting and they'll give members an
update okay cancel dinner and to
hopefully quick ones one for their newer
members amongst us what is there is that
a background of the concerts the ID CV
and project and second loss for your
though we could quickly summarize
essentially and in seconds for your
point remand is someone that's on those
projects have necessarily be part of the
reconveyance
no no is the short ones that I mean in
terms of the scope of the project it was
passed I think quite a lot of probably
been undertaken already today still why
not to do recommend it and place to find
some of that background information
instead learns I'm sure they want to I
can send you those minutes of the
various maintained
and any reports the public I can send
you as well and the private and
confidential ones as well beautiful
cruel new members so they put the
background yeah it's really yeah I'm
just thinking are there any other no
members feeling the same answer
oh but get to okay sorry yeah Felicity
to everybody because just Michael I'm
just sending already yeah I do think I'm
the recommendation to keep the
Constitution members as they are because
it's I can't see the point of bringing
in any new people as it's just been
pointed out two new members think you
know know what's going on there's been a
lot of work done on like 720 so I think
really if those members are available
and are willing to carry on I would say
let's do it okay the only ones are
actually still on councillor Cooper and
councillor Dre Bob copy them into
everything and in vibe into the
counsel for the hotels big pipe if you
counseled rate to continue and not even
ask how's the Cooper's well in
counseling Illinois see I teach them
okay counselor for them and yeah just
the the IT project again I guess I'm
about to previous client is so maybe
some of the limiting factors might move
it forwards a bit more no ideas might
necessarily say myself inclined to read
the reports anywhere interested then
you're absolutely bought a lot of them
to join the booking party but I think
but there was absolutely no issue with
any new members going on there
especially if they've got IT knowledge
or expertise it just certainly not gonna
be negatives their appreciation to the
key decisions
[Music]
okay number 119 remember the credit
debit card payments of carparks members
would be aware that there was a report
that circulated a week or so ago in
members dropped today's revised report
was issued and hopefully that might
answer some of the members of westerns
the decision notice will be out after
five working days in this was them
counselor Stanley had a particular issue
with as he spoke spoke to you about it
did me he didn't we had a long
conversation after training yet but
whether the new reports gonna satisfy
him or not I don't know but how can that
I think
next fry him not this Friday to public
Friday before the decision notice will
be issued so you know if members have
still got questions they should contact
the ad after that going on to the next
one three own team the only one to seven
air quality project airline the final
business case this one's been on there
for a couple of months now it's a
follow-up to the original investigation
that we're doing and 518 the housing
allocation policy computation now that's
finally coming to the policy of the
issue for the end of June then we have
618 the Environmental Health Service
plan to 18 and 19 which is an annual
item which just says how they're gonna
go about doing their service plan for
the year and the enemy 501 which you
hear me new one on there
easy chronic drug plan that's to bring
the implementation plan go before the
Planning Commission are there evidence
were looking at the development of the
local plan because it will be part of
that one too I'm pretty sure we want to
achieve that on the 4th of July I think
is there's planning policy on separately
yeah turn on the air pulls your I'm
sorry doesn't mean that it's going there
first as far as I'm aware yeah I would
think yeah actually the chairman of
things we need to clarify that but I
would think that would be wrong with our
ladies came to you know else there's a
meeting at 7:30 on the policy on the 4th
of July that my team I just clarify for
the days included in it I would make
sense to be yeah I'll tell them you're
expecting it yeah
okay members meeting finishes at 9:54
thank you all for coming